[音楽]
re re 連れしまーす
あれじゃでしょ tlr 新しい打ちましたよぷっには6本と4 ke jorge
あーして
ぞ本当お家さんをこのこんなしょうもないことについて全然もしれないですけど僕の
良いに
圧のお家に入ってに去ってからただけで泣けない犬は連れて辛くて
いやさんじゃない大丈夫だったなぜこれをするかというとやっぱりはいい人家でいる
みたいだけれどパソコンたらえって言ってみんな仲良いんでちょっとアットホームな
感じなんあ
せちゃってるんですよいいんですよずっといいんですけど
[音楽]
ブーブ的にパドゥピュードゥ
思った
肉会
うわぁ pt お家のコストで大家さんが突然いて普通に生活している時にやってき
ました
ブーブー
[音楽]
んだけど
えっ
[音楽]
のお世話なってます
花
人はよねったんで
2つ家であっ上でございます
すーげー応援さんが家に来て
[音楽]
ここです
好きですスレっスレっスレって
ch
[拍手]
[音楽]
tan
ええええええ
4がー
いまべつにいたの影響しませんさ逆に触れない方がいいのかなぁ
それない方がいいなぁ
ch
me
[音楽]
dee ん
[ __ ]っセレや入って焼いてこれは頭いいびっくりした今すごいさんですねうっ
応援 to do
あああああ脅かすか誰かより全然
でうみうしますよやっぱいい日常ですからね大谷来ないんですよね座りやすっ
me
バッハ